the notion of a half-life is useful if
we're dealing with increments of time
that are multiples of a half-life for
example after when at time equals zero
we have a hundred percent of our
substance then after time equal one
half-life we'd have 50% of our substance
at time is equal to two half-lives we'd
have 25% of our substance and so on and
so forth so if I say that three
half-lives have gone by and in the case
of carbon that would be what roughly
fifteen thousand years I can tell you
roughly or almost exactly how much what
percentage of my original element I
still have in the case of carbon-14 I'll
tell you what percentage of my original
carbon-14
has not decayed into nitrogen as yet
nitrogen-14
and that's useful but what if I care
about how much carbon I have after half
a year or after half a half-life or
after three billion years or after ten
minutes what if I want a general
function a general function as a
function of time that tells me the
number or the amount of my decaying
substance I have so that's what we're
going to do in this video and it's going
to be a little mathy but I think the
math is pretty straightforward
especially if you've if you've taken a
first year course in calculus and this
is actually a pretty neat application of
it so let's just think a little bit
about the rate of change or the
probability of or the number of
particles that are changing at any given
time so if we say then the difference
our change in our number of particles or
the amount of particles and in any very
small period of time in any very small
period of time what's this going to be
dependent on this is the number of
particles we have in a given period of
time this is our rate of change so we
one thing we know that our rate of
change is going down we know it's a
negative number right we know that in
the case of radioactive decay I could do
the same exercise with with with
compounding growth where I would say oh
no it's it's not a negative number that
our growth is dependent on how much we
have in this case the amount we're
decaying is proportional but it's going
to be the negative of how much of the
actual compound we already have let me
explain that so what I'm saying is look
our amount of decay is proportional to
the amount of the substance that we
already are dealing with and just a to
maybe make that a little bit more
intuitive imagine a situation here where
you have 1 times 10 to the ninth you
have a billion carbon atoms and let's
say over here you have 1 times 10 to the
6 carbon atoms and if you look at it at
over some small period of time let's say
if you look at it over one second let's
say our DT DT is an infinitesimally
small time but let's say it's a change
in time it's a delta T and let's say
over one second you observe that this
sample had I don't know let's say you
had you saw one thousand carbon
particles you really wouldn't see that
with carbon-14 but this is just for the
sake of our intuition let's say over one
second you saw one thousand carbon
particles per second here well here you
have one thousandth of the number of
particles in this sample as this one so
for every thousand particles you saw
decaying here you would really expect to
see one carbon particle per second here
just because you have a smaller amount
now I don't know what the actual
constant is but we know that no matter
what substance we're talking about this
this constant is dependent on the
substance carbon is going to be
different from uranium is going to be
different from you know we looked at
radon it's quote they're all going to
have different quantities right here and
we can see that we'll actually do in the
next video you can actually calculate
this from the half-life but the rate of
change is always going to be dependent
on the number of particles you have
right that's the I mean we saw that here
with half-life when you when you when
you have half the number of particles
you'll you you lose half as much right
here if we start with one hundred
particles here we went to fifty
particles and we went to twenty-five
when used twenty-five when you start
with 50 in a period of time you lose 25
when you start with 100 you lose 50 so
clearly the amount you lose is dependent
on the amount you started with right
over any fraction of time and here it's
this very small fraction so what I've
set up here is really a fairly simple
but it doesn't sound so simple a lot of
people if you say it's a differential
equation we can actually solve this
using pretty straightforward techniques
we just have to this
actually a separation of variables
problem and so what can we do let's
divide both sides by n so if we get we
want to get all the ends on this side
and all the T stuff on the other side so
if we have 1 over N DN over DT is equal
to minus lambda I just divided both
sides of this by N and then I can
multiply both sides of this by DT and I
get 1 over n D n is equal to minus
lambda DT
now I can take the integral of both
sides of this equation take the integral
and what do I get what's the
antiderivative I'm taking the indefinite
integral of the antiderivative of of 1
over N well that's the natural log the
natural log of n plus some constant plus
some constant I'll just do that in blue
plus some constant and then that equals
what's the antiderivative of just some
constant well it's just that constant
times the derivative the variable we're
taking the antiderivative with respect
to so minus lambda times T plus some
constant these are different constants
but they're arbitrary so if we want we
can just subtract that constant from
that constant and put them all on one
side and then we just get another
constant so this boils down to our
solution to our differential equation is
the natural log of N is equal to minus
lambda T plus some other constant out of
it I'll call it C 3 doesn't matter and
now if we want to just make this a
function of of N in terms of T let's
take let's take both let's take both of
these or both take e to the power of
both sides of this you can view that as
kind of the inverse natural log so e to
the power of Ln of n that's Ln of n is
just saying what power do you raise e to
to get to N so if you raise e to that
power you get n so if you I'm just
raising both sides of this equation I'm
raising e to both sides of this equation
so this e to the Ln of n is just n and
that is equal to e to the minus lambda T
plus C 3 and now this can be re-written
as n is equal to e to the minus lambda T
times e to the C 3 and now once again
this is an arbitrary constant so we can
just relate rename that is I don't know
let me rename it as c4 c4 so our
solution to our differential equation n
as a function of T is equal to our c4
constant c4 e to the minus lambda T now
let's say even better let's say at N
equals 0 let's say that n at N equals 0
we have n sub 0 of our of our sample
that's how much we're starting off with
so let's see if we can substitute that
into our equation to solve for c4 so we
say at n sub 0 n sub 0 is equal to let's
put 0 in here so let's see that's is
equal to n sub-nought and that's equal
to C 4 times e to the minus lambda times
0 well minus anything times 0 is 0 so
it's e to the 0 so that's just 1 so C 4
is equal to n not our starting amount
for the sample so we've actually got an
expression we have the number of
particles or the amount as a function of
T is equal to the amount that we start
off with at time is equal to 0 times e
to the minus lambda times time and we
just have to be careful that we're
always using the time constant when we
solve for the different coefficients so
the seems all abstract you know how does
this relate to half-life well let's
let's try to figure out this equation
for carbon this will be true for
anything where we have radioactive decay
if we actually had a plus sign here to
be radioactive it would be a exponential
growth as well we know that carbon C 14
has a as a 5,000 seven-year half-life
half life so the way you could think
about is this if at time equals zero you
start off with T at time equals zero so
time equals zero T equals let me write
that down if at end of zero is equal to
and we could write a hundred there if we
want actually why don't we do that if n
of 0 we start off with a hundred and
then at n of 5,700 years so we're going
to take T to be in years you just have
to be consistent with your units how
much will we have left we'll have 50
left we could have written x and x over
2 here and it would all worked out in
the end so let's see let's apply that to
this equation and try to solve this for
a lambda so we know n of 0 is equal to
100 so we immediately know that we can
write this equation as as n of T is
equal to 100 e to the minus lambda T at
least in the in this exact in this
circumstance in this circumstance right
and we also know that n of 5,700 so that
means n of 5,700 that is equal to we
just said we're after that's one half
life away so we have half as much of our
compound left that's equal to 50 which
is equal to this to the 5,700 power
times lambda so it's equal to 100 times
e to the minus lambda times 5,700 and
now we just solve for lambda then we'll
have a general equation for how much
carbon we have at any given moment in
time so if you divide both sides of this
by 100 what do we get we get 0.5 we have
1/2 1/2 is equal to e to the let me just
write minus 5,700 lambda and we could
take the natural log of both sides so
then we get just scroll down a bit
natural log of 1/2 is equal to the
natural log of this is just minus 5,700
lambda to solve for lambda you get
lambda is equal to the natural log of
1/2 / - 5,700 so let me see what that is
let's see what that is
so 0.5 natural log is that / - 5757
100 negative is equal to 1.2 times 10 to
the negative 4 it's equal to 1.2 1 times
10 to the 9 is 4 so there you have it we
figured out our lambda so the general
equation for how much carbon-14 we can
expect at any moment in time T where T
is and years is n of T is equal to the
amount of carbon we start off with times
e to the minus lambda e - um is 1.2 1
times 10 to the minus 4 times T in years
so now if you say after half a year you
just plug it in and you have to tell me
how much you started off with and then I
can tell you how much you have after
half a year or after a million years or
after a gazillion years and we'll do a
lot more of these problems in the next
video